now we take you to the world of computer
animation where director John Lasseter
has proved that a boy with a hard drive
can go a long way he and his team of
animators and technical artists at Pixar
have expanded the property lines of
virtual Realty with their movie Toy
Story where an oil old-fashioned cowboy
doll named woody boy I had a woody as a
child and what fun it was to play with
it in the morning and a high-tech space
ranger named buzz light you compete for
a place of honor in a young boy's heart
for one of the milestone achievements in
the hundred year history of film the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences presents his special
achievement award to John Lasseter and
here he is with the two stars of Toy
Story
thanks Robin you know I didn't bring
these guys they hired their own limo you
know it's a real small one Malibu Ken
was the was the driver before I get
started I wanted to thank the Academy
for their longtime support with student
filmmakers and of short films I stand
here proudly as a product of that
encouragement and although my name alone
is on this award I want to share it with
everyone at Pixar Animation Studios the
incredible little studio that made Toy
Story and to the Walt Disney Studios for
believing that we could do it Toy Story
was a labor of love that took over four
years to complete and even though it's
the first computer animated feature film
the group computers alone did not create
Toy Story a group of very talented
people did among them all right time you
Robin Anderson peek dr. Joe grant Ralph
Guggenheim Bonnie Arnold bill Reeves
Evan Osby Ralph Eccleston Peter
Schneider Tom Schumacher Michael Eisner
and every and everyone at Pixar
and also the United rhythm foundation
please help
and also my loving wife Nancy and my
lucky stars my sons Joey Bennett PJ and
Sam it's because of these people the sum
of all these brilliant parts that Toy
Story carries a human spirit that shines
even brighter than its computerized glow
so I thank the Academy Board of
Governors and the all the audiences
around the world for recognizing its
light thank you